go to shane in dayton ohio shane what's
going on
not much how are you guys we're doing
great thanks for calling what's up how
can we help
uh so just a little backstory my
parents are divorced they have been for
a while
my mom has been in a relationship
for a long time off and on with a
married man
uh-oh um so
and obviously uh everything i was taught
and raised up
with you know that's it's be more when i
don't you know
i don't support it okay um again this
you know this guy has been in out of my
life for a while now i you know i see
him every once in a while again
i don't like being around that situation
so my question is is
how can i talk to my mom about this
and let her know my feelings on it
because i feel like every time i do
you know she always gets defensive or
you know has every reason as to why she
should stay with him
this and that how old are you man i am
23. 23. you still live at home
uh no sir i live with my wife okay
so you don't have a lot of say in this
conversation
but right i do respect your desire to
have
to to be heard right so
what i would do is anthony
go out to dinner i'd go out to breakfast
right and i would go sit down and say
hey mom
i i don't i want you to know that i
don't like that you're in a relationship
with
a married guy you raised me differently
than that you gave me a set of values
that i've instilled in my soul
and this looks like you're not living
your own values
i love you you're my mom and you're a
grown woman you can do what you want to
and you have to be prepared prepared for
thee and then
she may say bye then right
and you've got to decide for yourself
how important this conversation is what
you're going to get out of it what
you're hoping to accomplish with this
conversation
and if you're going into it just so you
can make sure i was right i told her
what
and that's a dangerous way to enter a
conversation because you've got to deal
with the back end and the fallout
if you think she can hear you if you
think she um
respects your opinion and you have the
ability to go in and have a respectful
conversation to
to your mother then um man i think
that's a great conversation i would have
that conversation with my parents but i
would do it very humbly
and knowing my place what do you think
anthony
you know i'm like 50 50. and i'll be
honest i think 50
of me agrees with you like yeah i would
want to tell my mom like hey mama uh
this is not cool you're hurting someone
else's family you hurt
you don't know what's going on the other
side and you're a part
of that and i would definitely be scared
and nervous and then a part of me is
like
i'm married i have my own family
i need to worry about my family and not
create any more drama that can come into
my family
so part of him is like should i just
mind my own business
and the only and here's why i lean on
that side
if my mom was to bring him over my house
then it gives me permission
to now speak into it you know if if i
was to go over to the house with my wife
with my kids and he's over there then
that gives me
permission i'm not even saying something
to my mom i'm talking to i'm talking to
the married man
you know but it's like you're the expert
in this space well i don't think there's
an expertise as much as this is just
what i would do in my house
shane are you worried about him coming
over to your house being around your
kids being around your young family um
what's the impetus for this conversation
um it's more of just i want my mother to
be happy
um is this conversation gonna help her
be happy
i'll about to say because it sounds like
your mama's
happy yeah so and she's happy in the
wrong
way right
like i said they've been on and off for
i mean six years now and
let me ask you this question let me ask
you
is is he married as in living with his
wife or is he
married and separated not that even
worse it's better
to say yeah no they are they are married
and still living with each other yeah
yeah
so maybe she knows about it yeah shane
maybe try it this way
maybe take your mom out and say it's
been six years
since the divorce it's been six years
you've been off and on with this married
guy
i just noticed you're not happy and i
love you you raised me with a different
set of
values than this looks like you're
hurting it looks like you're struggling
looks like there's some guy in your life
that's taking advantage of you and i
love you as
as your son and now that i'm getting
older like
i just love you as as as my mom as a
friend
and um like what's going on your heart
tell me how i can help
maybe lean in towards it that way i do
think the boundaries conversation is
something that's going to come up sooner
rather than later yeah
right your wife um you and your wife
have kids and you decide i don't want
this guy around here
i think anthony's right i think the
harder more direct more integris
conversation is
with him absolutely um that's a hard
conversation of course
and especially if he's 55 year old man
he's his
he's not going to listen to a 22 year
old kid running his mouth at him
and again it's about respect and dignity
at the same time saying these are my
boundaries this is what
where i'm drawing the line in my house
for my family and
i don't want you around and i'm letting
your mom know you're gonna have that
conversation but that's down the road i
think right now you
sound like you're you don't like what
your mom's doing but you're worried
about your
the state of your mom's heart and so i
think that starts that's a different
it's a direct but it's a different
conversation there
and anthony so i
part of me gets your
i don't want to create any more drama in
my family i got my own i'm working
through heck yeah
the other side of it is it sounds like
mom brought drama to
the family she did right she did and
she's creating drama
in the other family sooner or later it's
going to come out
oh it is out the other woman knows right
yeah yeah
wait the other woman knows about his
mama yeah
oh my gosh yep see
that just couldn't be my mama man
because i i don't know if i can go with
my mom
in a very humble way my mom would be
upset with me because she would hear the
tone the passion
the fire in my soul you know
there's there's two problems that i see
here one you're creating drama in
another family then two you're settling
for less than who you are right you
deserve
a husband you deserve a man that focuses
on you you don't want a man to focus on
you and another woman
so why put another woman through that
crap and so you know that's why you're
the expert in this space because i would
probably respond
totally wrong and i'm gonna keep it i'm
gonna keep it 100
with our listeners uh because my mama
will my mama will probably smack me
uh my mom would probably tell me to
leave i'm gonna keep it 100 because
there's no way in the world i would tell
my mom
i love you but i've lost so much respect
for
the fact that you you would bring this
kind of drama and unnecessary
drama into our family and into another
home when you raise me so much better
than that so i it's so much
i don't think it's a professional
approach and i think for me it's
if if my mom is hurting for six years
still struggling wants connection
so badly that she's willing to
but you know what boundaries i want to
sit down and say hey something
something's something's wrong in your
heart man exactly are you okay
she's looking for an external fix to fix
something internal that's right
and so it's like she's looking for but
that's that's a relationship and
connection we're all looking for that
right absolutely but it's like
no fix the internal first because
internally she should know that she was
fearfully and wonderfully made
she should internally she should know
that hey i deserve
this and i'm settling for that right
and that is crap yeah you know i can't
cuss on this show
dave will come back and say you can no
longer be on this show but that's a
bunch of bs
you know and i just think that um
setting us up my emotions brother i'm
praying for you i'm praying for your
wife i'm praying for the other family
and i just believe that god can shift
some things and so that that's that's
the best advice that i can give at this
present time
because i probably just made half of
america upset right now with me
no i think that here's the the bigger
lesson for me
is we all have to have hard
conversations with people that we love
yeah
and the best we can approach that
conversation with
you're fighting a war that i have no
idea about
versus i'm coming at you with my virtue
i'm coming at you to beat you up with my
right and wrong answers instead of
sitting down saying are you okay
i think we can solve a lot of problems
this country if i sit down and say
brother sister how can i help not
you screwed up you're all right it's
good
it's way to let's just love each other
man this is the ramsay show